hello folks welcome to rational science
I'm still having a little bit of
problems with my throat it's getting
better uh it took a month for me to
recover uh
the inflammation I had everywhere from
the sinuses all the way all the passages
there and uh I guess I'm getting better
I don't know uh seems like it I feel a
little better today in the other days
anyways uh let's get on with the show
today we have uh several issues and I'm
going to start with this one
says uh
uh says please make a video on current
Nobel Prize winner
uh he should should have put an S there
winners because as always uh lately
they've been giving all these prizes to
uh lots of people you know usually three
okay and so the question is whether um
uh anyone alone is ever going to get a
noble again you know now it's always
divided into three they get a penny each
and a bottle of uh champagne I guess
yeah these people they won the Nobel
Prize this year okay in physics
supposedly physics mathematics that's
what they wanted in and here they are
let me present them okay
okay these are the Nobel Prize winners
these yeah this year
and uh yeah uh what did they invent what
did they come up with and you you would
have to go back almost to the 1980s to
figure out what these people propose or
or what they found out and it's got to
do with something called entanglement
okay
what is entanglement people say you know
I never heard of that maybe uh some
people have heard of epr Einstein
Podolski Rosen experiment epr it's a
thought experiment and that dates all
the way to what is it 1935 and that was
answered a few months later by Niels
Bohr who was on the other side of the
issue uh trying to defend quantum
mechanics against the attack of epr okay
and what was epr well epr is essentially
entanglement there you could say the
same thing okay they just change their
names the name of the experimental
thought experiment over the years and
supposedly they proved it later on okay
what's the issue here it is okay in a
nutshell here's entanglement for you
okay if you are afraid of words say oh
what do they mean by entanglement don't
worry it's kid stuff baby stuff okay a
little 10 year old can understand this
okay here it is okay we have
entanglement and questions why do two
photons right emitted from the same atom
spin in opposite directions although
miles uh apart okay so that's the whole
issue here you have an atom it shoots a
photon in opposite directions okay and
uh uh if you measure one of the photons
going clockwise the other one will go
counterclockwise and vice versa and if
you were to be able to
reverse the direction of that particle
of one of the particles the other one
instantly and that that's the key word
instant instantaneously right uh changes
direction as well okay so that's the
whole issue and the question is how do
you do this with particles okay there
you see the particles on the bottom
uh you know these particles especially
in the case of light they're talking
about photons and what are we saying
we're saying that all these photons in a
series right they're going through a
certain detector on one end
and what's happening if they're
measuring and they say well these are
pointed in a certain direction okay and
the ones on the other side they're
pointed in a different direction and
they were able to measure this at Great
distances and they said we don't
understand how one one
Photon right on uh one of the analyzers
uh is able to influence one on the other
side of the universe really uh
instantaneously how can it possibly do
that okay so that was the whole issue
and um Neil's born in Einstein they
debated this issue uh personally and
also through uh articles that they wrote
that they authored okay and this is more
or less a summary of how each side
thought or what each side proposed okay
here you have it
the elements of physical reality which
are objectively possessed cannot be
influenced what
instantaneously at a distance that was
the whole issue from Einstein's point of
view the word instantaneous they could
not make sense of it they could not make
mathematical sense of that okay that
that was the issue okay so uh what was
um Niels Bohr answer it was their
arguments referring to epr right uh
Einstein polowski and Rosen their
arguments do not justify their
conclusion that the quantum description
okay turns out to be essentially
incomplete
so both sides uh were essentially
arguing uh whether it was feasible at
this point and uh in the case of boar he
was just talking about a description
whereas Einstein was talking about an
explanation he was saying you know how
do you instant how do you influence
something instantaneously when he had
already proven supposedly mathematically
right through uh special relativity that
the speed of light is the maximum speed
of the universe and it travels at 300
000 kilometers per second so if that was
the finite speed or the maximum speed
limit what was this instantaneous stuff
that they were bringing in with uh with
epr and with uh entanglement what became
known as eventually as entanglement
and uh Neil is born never came up with a
mechanism he just said there are no
hidden variables there okay uh locally
to make this happen he just said it
happens it is so that's all he said
essentially and uh what came later on uh
here were the experiments of these
fellows uh aspect and a couple others
and uh they said experiments verified to
entanglement they verified in town they
in other words they confirmed that
entanglement occurs okay aspects
experiment imply that a hypothetical
coordination signal travels twice as
fast as c c being the velocity of light
and another fellow there reached 10
million times C in his experiment so he
says
um essentially it was instantaneous so
what these people were doing is
measuring and to confirm that uh the
description was correct in other words
the one proposed by quantum mechanics
slash Niels Bohr that it was correct
that it did indeed indeed happen in uh
real life that was not just a thought
experiment as Einstein Podolski and
Rosen proposed it was in it actually
happened
and they never explained it they never
gave you a mechanism even to this day
there is no mechanism they gave these
people an ex a noble for
um essentially running an experiment
confirming the description that yeah it
troubles you could say instantaneously
with 10 million times the speed of light
and that's about as instantaneous as it
gets and that's the best they could
measure uh and so this is what they do
they measure and they say oh the
description is correct
but they never explain how Mother Nature
does the trick
so we still don't have an answer from
the mathematical establishment okay on
entanglement to this day and he said you
can look at anywhere and they say it's
true
it happens okay so it's true it happens
how does it happen especially if you're
sending particles one way or waves you
want waves we'll do waves no problem you
send them one way
okay it has to travel does it travel
instantaneously is that what you're
saying okay because we're talking again
one-way flow of whatever
and how do we do it under the Rope model
well uh kids stuff baby stuff okay so uh
you do not need to take any math you did
not need to go to college if you're a
eight-year-old nine-year-old 10 year old
kid I think you're going to understand
this quite well okay here it is okay uh
do we have to explain anything
absolutely not but I'll explain
something in the background here you
will see the images of what entanglement
is okay how Mother Nature does this
magic trick okay and here it is once you
connect every atom in the universe with
a rope-like entity then a rope being the
carrier you could say of light in other
words the Rope torsion on the Rope local
torsion on the Rope is already light and
so you do not have anything moving
really from A to B what you have is
simply a rope that is torquing from the
other side of the universe all the way
to this side of the universe so an atom
on the other side of the universe that
is connected to an atom on this side of
the universe have a rope torquing in a
certain direction okay and if you're on
one end of that you would see that it's
clockwise if you're on the other end you
had better C counterclockwise that's
that's essentially the whole thing and
um
uh here um I'll show you something else
here
give me a second here
um for those of you who are not familiar
we're looking at the construction of the
atom and the Rope okay and here it is
okay that's what our atom looks like you
see the ropes impinging on the surface
of the atom okay and here you see the
construction okay one thread which will
arbitrarily call the electric thread
goes through the center of the atom and
many of those from every atom in the
universe form a proton star the magnetic
thread coils around forms the electron
shell that encapsulates the proton star
and you can see how all those ropes are
connected to every atom in the universe
and that's what the atom looks like so
what you have here is that the atom
itself is connected to the robe is
connected to another rope on the other
side but these ropes form the atom
itself it's a continuous entity in other
words the thread just moves throughout
the whole universe there's a single
thread in the entire universe so we can
see why if the atom torques right if the
atom torques then what you will have is
a
that
from one atom's point of view it's going
to be clockwise and from the other point
of view it's going to be
counterclockwise if somehow you were
able to reverse the direction of that
rope right again I usually have it with
my room here you know from my end yeah
let's see there we go from my end it's
going counterclockwise hopefully from
your end I can do this better here from
my end it's going counterclockwise from
your end it should be going clockwise
and now if I reverse it from you from my
end it's going clockwise from your end
head better go counterclockwise
very simple stuff okay with a rope it's
baby stuff kids stuff with particles oh
man
you'll never get it with particles okay
so uh that's in a nutshell obviously
there are many questions that pop up
with entanglement in in the context of
the rope and that's a full hour at least
uh you know lecture there I'm not going
to go into all those details because I
know there are lots of questions that
people have I'm just saying that under
the Rope model it's very simple uh
concept for you to conceptualize to
visualize what is happening from your
end it's going clockwise
rockaways are like that for me and for
you from your end should be going
counterclockwise any rope and so the
question is you know again uh what rope
are we measuring you know that's one
issue there are many issues really
involved and again it takes I would have
to spend an hour on all the questions
that people would have
um uh once they look at the model okay
so that's all I can tell you okay
another fellow that wants me to talk a
little bit about Extinction he says
there are forecasts of incoming uh
famines due to current policies uh-huh
uh would you like to address the topic
of human extinction again it's so
freaking interesting
well the incoming famines like you know
we've always had famine uh on Earth you
know in different parts of the world uh
those have nothing to do with the
extinction okay that I'm talking about
when I'm talking about a famine uh I'm
talking about a global collapse of the
economy the entire uh economy of the
world collapses that's different than
saying oh there there are people who are
suffering in I don't know Nigeria yeah
you know people suffer uh hunger in
different parts of the world at
different points in history at times in
history Etc uh that's not what I'm
talking about there's always been
famines there's the Russian famine in
the uh right after the Civil War you
know uh I mean countless famines
throughout history what I'm talking
about is the total collapse of the
global economy when not if but when that
happens okay
um you know uh nobody will will have any
incentive to produce or distribute food
to the city so especially the
agriculture corporations agricultural
corporations
you know what would be their incentive
if money is no more that's what I mean
by economic collapse no one accepts
money anymore of any kind uh Bitcoin
gold uh whatever because it will have no
value because you will not be able to
unload it to someone else
okay that's what I'm talking about and
again that's a long story not getting
into that but I can comment about is a
little bit of what's going on today and
I haven't commented in a couple weeks
now because really we have very little
information for example what's going on
in the war in Ukraine we only get one
side of the picture the others I guess
their own side of the picture and so
they're kind of not talking to the Press
right it's not talking to each other and
here I'll I'll pull up uh this uh this
thing that caught my attention uh Miss
Yellen here she's the treasury Secretary
of United States and she said the
following in a I guess a speech she gave
Russia's economy will struggle to grow
due to the Fallout from its war on
Ukraine uh economists have forecasts
Russia's economy to contract by over six
percent this year and four percent in
2023. sanctions will create a dragon on
Russia's growth prospects for years to
come Yellen said okay so what's the deal
the United States States essentially
is is trying to break the Russian
economy uh and with that hopefully
trigger not only the end of the war in
Ukraine but overthrow the Russian
government that that is the long-term
goal and
um there are several things involved
there because you know this would mean
that Russia would be incorporated within
the U.S Empire the United States Empire
has already conquered uh Great Britain
with brexit uh about three four years
ago and then they moved on to what we
have today which is the um the uh
Europeans especially the Germans and the
French and they conquered uh these
countries without firing a single shot
now that's good politics
not a single American was lost I mean
maybe someone died over there you know
I've heard that a couple of Americans
die in Ukraine that's not that's not
losses
but I mean that United States did not
have to send military and kill a bunch
of people and so on they're just sitting
you know drinking their beer and
watching how the Russians kill each
other that's and that's not bad politics
okay so it's rough on the Russians
whether the sanctions will produce that
the Russian government Falls which is
the ultimate goal that's a different
story it might work it might not and all
I can say on that in that respect is
that China will certainly do everything
possible to prop up the Russians because
if Russia Falls and falls in the hands
of the United States and becomes another
star in the flag
then it's just China
and at least in the short run and by
short run I mean maybe the next 10 years
I don't think China will be able to
catch up so quickly with the United
States militarily especially and so the
Chinese are hoping that Russia does not
fall and they will do everything
possible to help Russia out so uh we'll
find out what happens that's the war
there what's more important is what
effect does all this have on the global
economy now that's a different story and
what I see there now I can tell you is
my personal opinion here you know is
that uh Russia I'm sorry the United
States is having economic problems very
gravy economic problems and I think
that's one of the reasons they had to
conquer Europe because they had to
expand the Empire as long as you grow
you know the Empire grows then you're
okay you know it's when the Empire
doesn't stops growing doesn't continue
growing like it happened to the roads
happened to the Greeks to the Persians
once you stop growing then you have
problems as long as you grow you know
then you have some few a few more years
uh of life and the American Empire is
doing quite well in that sense it's
conquered Europe now or is in the
process of doing so it's going to take
some years to adjust some of these
things hopefully it's years not months
as the American Empire expands and uh
you know it might be good for the global
economy you know for for at least for
survival for lasting more years I'm not
sure they can keep that up whether
Russia Falls or not I'm not sure they
can keep it up even if China Falls okay
the American Empire cannot be allowed to
full fall too big to fail okay that's
all I can tell you and so when the U.S
Empire Falls We All Fall no matter what
okay and uh I think that's well that's
the way I look at it uh anyways um let
me say something about other theories
extinction theories
or some something you should keep in
mind about extinction theories okay and
the most famous Extinction Theory
related to mass extinction is the one of
the dinosaurs okay and the ruling Theory
today for several years now in fact
since 1980 has been the Alvarez uh
Extinction Theory okay and that's the
asteroid that hit the earth and killed
the dinosaurs in one way or another okay
that impact Theory okay
and what I want to point out is how
politics is done in science here because
this is all about politics and nothing
at all about Extinction or about
mechanisms okay which is what people
want to know they want to know or
understand right how did the dinosaurs
die what killed them you know and we're
not only talking about the dinos they
were on land how about the reptiles in
the Seas how about the reptiles that
were flying overhead you know how did
they die especially the ones in the seas
and
um and so we don't have mechanisms for
how these animals die that's the that's
the true situation today okay all they
say that nastro everybody said okay that
explains everything everybody went home
and for the last 40 years we had this
asteroid Theory okay so what's the
problem well let's start here this is uh
uh this is Alvarez paper okay uh 1980
okay this is the one that broke uh all
the uh Records in paleontology uh by the
way Luis Alvarez is not a paleontologist
biologist okay it was not in you know
he's no longer around but what did he
say well this is what he his uh paper
said impact of a large asteroid the
resultant Darkness would suppress
photosynthesis and because of that all
the plants died and then all the animals
died that's essentially the theory
that's how quick it is okay he talks
about something which is irrelevant
talks about prediction and he predicts
the past he predicts something about
what happened 65 million years ago
Cretaceous and tertiary okay uh boundary
and um and then he talks about estimates
of the diameter of the asteroids how big
it was how much it weighed all this kind
of stuff that concerns mathematicians
and does not concern us at all who are
interested in mechanisms we want to know
how the what killed the dinosaurs how
they die what exterminated them and
these people are saying let me tell you
how big the asteroid was but we don't
even know if the asteroid kill them
because you cannot explain a mechanism
was it the hit the strike is that what
killed the dinos all the dinosaurs on
the other side of the planet as well and
he said no see this created waves uh we
had all this um uh debris in the air
created a uh uh impact winter as it's
called so the sun couldn't get in the
plants died so they go through this all
this rigmarole okay this whole story and
still they cannot explain how the ones
in the uh in the Seas died and for that
they had to say well the asteroid landed
on sulfuric acid and sulfuric created
some acid that killed the animals or
maybe there was some acid rain they have
all these theories out there sub
theories from the impact okay uh in
other words they they created a a
Theory or a mechanism for each species
for this one we're going to use the
sulfuric acid for that one we're going
to use the acid rain for that one we're
going to say the impact where the other
one will say great ocean uh tsunamis you
know drown them so they have all these
different theories to explain how
different animals died around the world
and by the way that's exactly the same
thing you'll find for the Permian
Triassic or division you'll find it for
all the all the theories that they have
have all these Splinter theories how did
the animals and and again the Big
Brothers how do you kill the animals in
the water as well as the one in the land
that's a big problem and they never be
were able to solve it with one mechanism
they have to create a secondary
mechanism to kill the guys on land from
the guys in the Seas okay and the first
thing I want to mention is that the
theory the so-called theory is the
mechanism okay and what is the mechanism
the mechanism is asteroid hits the Earth
in other words the cause the primary
cause is an extraterrestrial impact
that's it that's the whole Theory you
can just synthesize it in that phrase uh
extraterrestrial impact okay that's what
caused it all and that theory was
already around since 1955.
um or 56 sorry uh Max de lowbenfels he
was the first one who came up with a
theory uh 24 years before the the
Alvarez did I mean that's the whole
thing and he says in his paper he says
from intensely hot winds such as would
be generated by what extra large
meteoritic or
um planetesimal impacts okay so he
already talked about an impact uh
causing the extinction of the dinosaurs
and he just suggested is you know
there's just one more theory for you to
consider that's the way he wrote his
paper Okay turns out he wasn't the first
one either because when you go back in
time you find out that the French in the
18th century let me repeat that 18th
century 1700s late 1700s already talked
about impacts okay here's a one paper
really more like a book that was written
I'm just gonna put this up there and I'm
gonna read it all okay but this was a
theories of terrestrial mass extinction
by extraterrestrial objects
so uh this fellow talks about you know
how Peter LaPlace already talked about
impacts extraterrestrial impacts and
we're talking about the end of the 18th
century beginning of the 19th century so
we're talking about 1700s 1800s okay
they already talked about that
um in fact uh there was someone else who
actually talks about the uh I I wasn't
able to find him anymore but um I'm
gonna look for him again I've talked
about him in the past and he was a
french guy he he said the dinosaurs died
because an impact hit the earth that was
his proposal everyone thought about that
one of the first things they said well
maybe something from from outside the
Earth hit the earth caused tsunamis or
whatever and that's what killed the
animals everyone thought about that 200
years ago so the lobenfels it wasn't the
first one we have this going all the way
to the 18th century and that is the
theory
so you asked them what did the Alvarez
how come they're so famous how come they
made the theory so famous what did they
invent what did they uh add to the
theory I mean if the theory is impact we
kill them we're done right what did
these people add and so this is what uh
Alvarez added okay uh he presented what
is very important for mathematicians
around the world and that's evidence
persuasion conversion convert me
prove to me
okay that's what it was all about so he
said we present what evidence
that's what he talked about in his paper
and that's how he started his paper
okay and let me show you again very
quickly here these are the headings of
each one of the segments in his paper
none of them talk about an explanation a
cause a mechanism
only the one that says biological
effects all the rest was just evidence
measurements
uh how big the thing was uh and it
couldn't have been something else it had
to be an asteroid and this kind of thing
okay and only only that little
uh five paragraph section small
paragraphs was the only one discussing
the actual Theory the mechanism how the
animals became extinct
so let's look at that one real quickly
okay so you can see what the theory is
all about so that you can understand
perfectly well how each of the dinosaurs
in the land in the Seas everywhere die
the ones in the air you know
pterodactyls and so on this is how they
died okay here it is okay it says
absence of light sunlight shut off
photosynthesis and attack the food
chains okay great then he goes into the
ocean plants you know the algae uh he
went to the land plants and then he goes
and he says why did some animals survive
especially the mammals he said they may
have been able to do this by feeding on
insects and decaying vegetation in other
words the Treatise okay and then he says
shallow marine body bottom dwelling in
invertebrates uh you know some groups
became exchange and others survived so
you have to explain that as well and
again he he just says nutrients
originating from decaying land plants an
animal blah blah blah in other words the
tritus that's how the animals that
survived survive because of the tritus
that's answer did he explain exactly
what the mechanism was absolutely not
but I like the last paragraph This one I
will read he says we will not go further
into this matter he's not going to tell
us the theory the mechanism because he
doesn't understand Squad about anything
that's the reality but we refer the
reader to the proceedings of the 1976
Ottawa meeting on the Cretaceous
tertiary Extinction this volume
reproduces an extensive discussion among
the participants of what would happen if
the sunlight were temporarily turned off
in other words he says uh go screw
yourself yeah
you want to know the mechanism go read
that uh thing that's a theory just go
read uh whatever was in the thing
meanwhile all he talked about is
evidence he says I got evidence oh
what's your evidence oh there was a
bunch of iridium
covering the Earth
okay that's all his evidence later on
they say oh we found an uh you know the
chick salub um crater supposedly
underneath the Mexican uh area of the
Gulf of Mexico okay and they said okay
we we found uh the impact and so the
theory is confirmed we're all done and
everybody went home and that's what we
have today
and yeah so far we have no mechanism we
have no idea especially uh of what is
known as selectivity that's the only
thing that a mass extinction and even a
background Extinction has to explain how
do you isolate one group of animals and
leave the others alive how do you
isolate one group of plants and if the
others alive
what is a mass extinction The
Disappearance of a food chain how do you
make a food chain disappear
if you throw uh something that will kill
them all or will affect them all equally
across the board
and that's exactly not what occurred in
65 million years ago what occurred is
that the mammals survived without any
problem
and all the dinosaurs were gone the
dinosaurs were the old animals the
ancient animals that were due for
extinction and the mammals were very
recent uh animals the mammals were the
recent animals that
expanded when the big guys were gone
does that sound like an asteroid to you
well it doesn't sound like one to me
okay and so yeah uh and the other thing
I want to say about uh Extinction is
um
brought up and this is it it's got to do
with prediction they don't understand
exactly a lot of these uh uh poor
fellows you know they they're lost
completely they think a prediction is
when you tell me that tomorrow at two
o'clock the uh uh there's gonna be an
eclipse
so far we have a prediction
but if I can explain to you why there's
going to be an eclipse tomorrow
it's no longer an ex a prediction now
I'm giving you an explanation in
explanations you can only explain the
past
and these people never understood that
argument and I think they never will so
this is where you where you start he
says you state because of X mechanism
humans will go extinct but that is not a
prediction
yes it is not a prediction okay and I
guess what makes him think it's a
prediction uh is because he sees the
word will you know uh won't will talking
about the future so he said okay uh
you're talking about the future that's a
prediction well so we look up the word
prediction in the dictionary it says
prediction to declare or tell in advance
to prophecy to foretell the Future Okay
so the dictionary makes prediction
prophecy and foretelling synonyms
essentially okay
saying they're all the same Wikipedia
more or less the same a statement about
a future event okay that's what they say
what is prophecy foretelling or
prediction of what is to come something
that is declared by a prophet
specifically especially a divinely
inspired prediction okay so we have
prophecies uh demand inspired uh
prediction but they're both the same
essentially and Wikipedia says also
prophecy a message that has been
communicated to a person typically a
prophet right by Supernatural entity so
the entity Whispers in your ear and
you're a prophet because now you you
know you're in tune with
where the transcendental world and they
can tell you exactly you know what's
coming uh in the future so you spread
that around okay but those are the
definitions of ordinary speech those are
not the definitions of science that's
not what a prediction is so let's make
sure we understand at least the
difference between a prediction a uh
prophecy and an explanation especially
those three okay here it is okay Rundown
okay there will be an eclipse that's a
prophecy I didn't give you a time I
don't I'm not saying when it's going to
happen could happen in a million years I
won't be around anyways except to say
that there will be an eclipse
you know okay so what have you said
nothing
okay
uh what's a prediction of this it's just
a description all you're doing is
describing okay let's make sure we
understand that part there will be an
eclipse tomorrow at 2 pm
okay that's a prediction because you're
giving a specific time now we can all
verify whether your prediction comes
true that's no longer a prophecy and you
know open-ended uh foretelling or
you know the prophecy to use a different
word to use the same word okay
um So when you say there will be one at
two o'clock tomorrow you've been a
prediction but so far all you have is a
description all you said this will
happen
you haven't told me the cause you
haven't told me the mechanism you
haven't give me an explanation for why
you think or what the mechanism is why
it's going to happen
okay
what's an explanation there will be an
eclipse because the moon will come
between the Earth and the Sun
that's not a prediction that's not a
prophecy that's not foretelling okay the
fact that I use the word will
has nothing to do with prophecy in this
context here we're saying look I'm
giving you the mechanism you got to
focus on the mechanism not on the word
will okay or won't in case it's will not
right uh you're you got to focus on the
mechanism what am I explaining to you
I'm saying I'm giving the mechanism why
it's going to happen and you have to
focus on the uh on on the inevitable
mechanism okay so it's the mechanism
that you got to focus on not really so
much the inevitability
so here's a regarding extension men will
soon become extinct
so far we said nothing that's a
description and it's an open-ended one I
have no time I have no idea when it's
going to happen it could happen a
million years
so man's gonna become extinct we haven't
said anything the last human will die on
the first of February of 2030.
now I've given you not a prophecy this
is really a prediction because I'm
giving you a date and time when it's
going to happen maybe time all right
I'll give you a date I'm telling you
when it's going to happen so now you say
okay maybe I can verify that prediction
see if it came true but so far you have
a description
so far I haven't given you an
explanation why I think what my theory
is of why it's going to happen
and there on the bottom you see an
explanation humans will go extinct
because there will be no food okay
now now you don't focus on the word will
now you focus on the there will be no
food that's the cause that's an
explanation where did I get this where
did I get the
um uh eclipse
from past experiences explanation you
can only explain the past okay and this
is where people who use the word will
they say oh you're talking about the
future no I'm talking about the past
what the theory of Extinction is of man
in fact of man himself has to do with
mechanism
it has to do with how did animals die in
the past man is going to die in the same
way that's what we're saying okay that's
not a prediction because you're focusing
on the wrong aspect you have to focus on
the mechanism then you'll understand why
man is going to become extinct
do we have a date we don't care about
the date okay well we do care but we
don't know the date only I guess God
Mother Nature father Universe one of
those God the devil one of those guys
might know when we don't know when all
we can say is this is the mechanism
that's going to kill us because it's the
mechanism that killed all species in the
past we're just applying this cookie
cutter that uh was applied into Permian
and the Triassic and the Cretaceous
we're going to apply it to man to the
um uh quaternary okay that's essentially
the situation
let's get to the subject matter today
and that's uh
God
what in the world is God a lot of people
pray to God
a lot of people say God is in them talks
to them
okay so we start here we start with
atheism
who is an Atheist Atheism person who
says claims that he does not believe in
the existence of God that's essentially
he believes there is no God out there
okay and by the way I do clarify all the
time that I was an atheist for most of
my life
okay I was brought up in a an atheist
environment my folks were militant
atheists they were not just middle of
the road atheists they were uh among the
first contributors to American atheists
when it started out in Baltimore over
there we lived there at the time and we
were friends with Madeline Murray O'Hare
who later on was murdered a few years
later
anyways
um so I come from an atheist background
and the first thing I want to say I'm no
longer an atheist in fact they are my
number one enemies
so I changed side but did I go to the
other side did I become a religious uh
am I a Christian am I a Muslim Buddhist
or a Hindu
no I consider all those religions in
fact I'm not even sure we can call uh
atheism a religion I think it's uh
irrationality okay and we'll get to that
in a second but let me show you this
um
so so no I'm what is called a scientist
and a scientist is not an atheist
science goes completely against atheism
antheism and agnosticism against all
three of them okay why we'll find out
but here to start with this and this uh
I found this week
uh so this is what an atheist does this
is an atheist dog okay by the way the
word dog is the opposite of the word God
okay keep that in mind okay but here is
this is what a dog does an atheist dog
does okay and he says None I see I
mistake for a tree
that's the ethos dog okay so uh what's
the issue
this uh why am I not an atheist what are
atheists why do I object to atheism and
agnosticism by the way because a lot of
agnostics uh not agnostices were are
also
um in a sense atheist uh they'd rather
not believe them believe okay so I put
them essentially all of them in the same
boat together with it with Theus more or
less okay so here it is okay this is the
rundown okay atheism the religion of the
mathematicians okay it's the religion of
mathematics
it's the mathematical physicists who
talk about
atheism and and spread the religion of
atheism
what's wrong with atheism well it has to
do with belief that's what's wrong with
atheism atheism Hearts unbelief because
the so-called scientific method of the
uh mathematicians is irrational it's an
irrational
system method okay and because of that
they concluded that uh science is about
belief that science is about opinion and
that's what they harp on they try to
convince you they try to persuade you
that they are right that they are
correct that's what it's all about and
that's not what science is about that's
an irrational scientific method we do
not uh have opinions in science we do
not have beliefs in science we explain a
mechanism objectively so that you
understand it and that's where science
stops what continues is religion and so
what are the mathematicians harp on they
harp on evidence proof knowledge
verification verify
verify what he with the experiment the
other guy uh ran and what do you learn
from that you learned the description
you say Okay I uh I'll verify that uh
the pencil you know falls to the floor
okay I verified repeatable experiment
just do it again you know and so you got
at least uh two uh
instances to uh experiments now you can
say you it's scientific so you verified
what did you verify a description you
can even say well how fast it went or
what what's the acceleration doesn't
matter you can measure all that and
verify all that still you have no
explanation you have no mechanism for
what caused the pencil or pen to fall to
the floor rather than to the ceiling
consistently so that's where the problem
is and so they harp on persuasion
convincing converting and recruiting
they try to persuade you that they are
correct that they are right that they
have proof and this comes from
mathematics where they prove
um you know equations like this equation
gives you that result and so on and it
uh describes a certain action so it's
got to do with that with what the word
proof means in mathematics in science we
have no proof because proof means I
convince you I twisted your arm and made
you think the way I do that's what proof
means okay and once you have proof you
have knowledge and once you have
knowledge you have nothing more to learn
correct
in other words uh now nobody can
convince you otherwise because you know
and that's that's all there is so no
knowledge belongs to religion in science
we do not know
science has nothing to do with knowledge
science has to do with explanation and
understanding and that's where science
stops what continues is known as
religion now it's proof evidence doesn't
belong in science at all okay so what's
the issue the issue is that um uh
related to God right is that they never
Define the word exist a mathematician an
atheist okay has never defined the word
exist so it remains an undefined term
even to this day what they have is
synonyms
which is a circular definition uh you'll
find these synonyms uh in the
dictionaries living to be being actual
real reality stuff like that those are
all synonyms because when you look up
those words actuality reality whatever
you'll find a word exists in there that
we're being it's just a circular the
whole thing is circular you won't find a
definition what do you mean by exist and
no one in the last three thousand years
defined the word exists and so atheists
are in that boat and they use the word
exist without having defined it they
don't know exactly what they mean by
exist they say well you know what I mean
by exist uh no I don't well please
please define the word exists and so we
have an unspecified uh situation here
it's got an object or a concept okay uh
and uh objects is that which has shape
so does God have shape or not so we have
two issues related to God and here are
the two issues okay
uh and this is in my book people say God
why did you name it why God doesn't
exist and people focus on the word God
and they should be focusing on the word
exist okay I Define the word exists for
the first time in in history uh I'm not
bragging here I'm just stating a fact
nobody ever defined a word exists so
nobody knows what they mean when they
say God exists or God doesn't exist so I
don't know whether God exists or not uh
they never Define the word exists so
they don't know what they're saying and
I'm saying you have to define the word
exists so that we understand what you're
saying when you say God exists or God
doesn't exist okay and so these are the
two questions of God related to physics
why because people say why are you
bringing the word god into physics I
thought that belonged in religion no no
it's the word exists that we're
concerned about it's the word object
that we're concerned about and you got
to tell me whether God is an object
first and if God is an object a thing
then if God exists or not and God is a
concept well you know you're going to
have a hard time and here it is it's got
an object or a concept and does God
exist those are the two issues of God
related to physics that's why we bring
them into physics because the word
exists belongs exclusively to physics
physics is the science of existence
that's what the book has to do with okay
and yeah I do talk about God I think the
last chapter 10 chapters the last one
um but that's not the issue the issue
with God is
um whether he exists or not whether he's
an object whether he's a thing
and I say he I should say whether God is
an object whether God is a thing that's
what you got to tell me and if you
approach a Christian a Muslim uh Hindu
whatever out there Orthodox Christian of
uh Greeks or Russians or whatever any
religion that has this God out there
you have to ask him only one question
and you'll and you'll stumble I know
because I tried it already many times
and you ask him is that an object or a
concept an object that would chest shape
a concept is that which does not have
shape does God have shape does God not
have shape
that's the only issue and the guy will
go Bonkers that's that's essentially uh
what it is okay and so
uh this is the question okay it's got an
object or a concept if God is an object
then he would he would say uh well he
looks like a man
you know he's got arms legs he's got a
belly button
maybe you know maybe he's got a mother I
don't know uh or maybe he's a bush
you know if you read the Bible the Old
Testament you'll find the Flaming Bush
story
yeah you know Moses he came up against
the Flaming Bush and was God talking him
from the bush so you could say that God
is a bush you know that's fine
no problem you pray to a bush no problem
I can I can deal with it okay as long as
it's an object we're no Pro no problem
but if God is a concept you know love
intelligence God is energy he's a spirit
it is a spirit I should say no God is a
spirit God is soul God is kind God is
talking to me okay God is consciousness
maybe you're just dreaming you know
talking to yourself you think oh God is
in there okay omniscience goodness you
know Etc Alpha and Omega
if God is a concept
then we have a problem because uh you
can't talk about the existence of God
because no concept can be said to exist
not in science not in a rational way you
can only say it in ordinary speech in
mathematics and all those religions you
can you can say whatever you want if
you're going to try to prove the
existence of God you know a lot of
Christians are into that uh Christians
and Muslims as well okay come on over
but now you step the line into physics
now you're going to have to follow
certain rules you're going to have to
define the word exist
and the word exists says that only
objects can exist
and uh uh they exist only if they have
location
and if you're a Christian you might say
well I don't like any of those
definitions bill
no problem
give me your definitions that you can
use consistently in a rational way
okay now I get an answer from people in
uh in a conference where I was they were
from Palestinians we went to lunch
together and uh they were all religious
and so I asked them the question is got
an object or a concept one guy said well
I think he's an object the other guy
says I think he's a concept the other
guy said well I don't know and the other
guy says uh if I knew what God was he
would be so great
so these are the kind of answers you're
going to get of course they can't Define
because they're going to step on their
own toes if they say it's an object then
he can't talk about love and
intelligence or Consciousness or
anything like that if he says the
concept well God doesn't exist by
definition because you have to have an
object and so on down the line and if
God is an object and he exists well
exists means that he's got shaping he's
got location within the universe meaning
you should be able to establish distance
meaning location of God with respect to
you there's got to be a straight line of
direction from God to me his chest to my
chest and then you can say he exists by
definition because God is has a human
figure no problem anthropomorphic God
and God has location because there's
distance between my chest and gods so
with definitions alone you prove right
that God exists but then you have to
live with it you know God now exists and
you have to deal with God he can't be
outside the universe he can't be in The
Fifth Dimension none of that nonsense he
can't be time right synonym of time so
it's not so easy to say oh God is out
there you know
okay so uh
yeah let's see give me a second here
so yeah uh God the object got uh only an
object uh can exist be said to exist and
that when an object is defined as that
which has shape okay exists physical
presence meaning an object plus location
okay so God can only set to exist if he
has if he's an object and then that's
not enough he's got to have in addition
he's got to have location
okay
um
what's happened here all these years
well if if you were to come back and go
back in time you know time travel uh
Einstein like you take The Time Tunnel
train
and you go two thousand three thousand
years ago those people those uh
predecessors those uh uh forefathers
that we had
they actually believe that God
was a human-like figure anthropomorphic
God that's what they believed
and that's what they put in the books
you know look at the Bible look at some
of these others like I talked about the
trip attack a little bit the other day
uh for the Buddhists they actually
believe that there were human-like
figures out there transcendental
human-like figures that intervene in
human Affairs they actually believe that
well that's been whittled down over the
years that's uh diluted over the years
and what's happened really is that today
especially the young people they don't
believe in that anthropomorphic God so
when you say well do you believe in God
he said yeah I do believe in God okay so
what is God and they say well God is
love God is intelligent they give you
all these Concepts
so the famous God who was an
anthropomorphic guy with you know hands
and magic wand and so on that guy more
or less is fading away if not
disappeared almost completely in the
minds of Many religious folk today and
what you see is this you know you have
on the one hand you have Concepts on the
other side you have objects and you have
God angels
Spirits you know Casper the Friendly
Ghost all those had shaped they imagined
them the things that floated in the air
you know that unseen things but they
said yeah god of the wind you know
aeolus he he blows
and that's the wind you know so they had
an explanation for why there was wind
there's this guy that blows and you had
the god of the seas Poseidon and so on
they had all these Gods god of the
underworld you know Hades okay so we had
all these Gods then they morphed them
into one God you know uh the next
generation of religious people they put
them into one God and today that God
that physical God has for the most part
disappeared you know even many pastors
they'll talk about God but they'll say
God is love and they go to the new
testament which is more abstract than
the uh uh Old Testament the New
Testament talks about love and God is
Spirit the Old Testament said no God is
a guy that's got you know hands arms and
he Wills certain things I can pray to
him because he's a he he's got a mind
you know he's another human up there
essentially made us in His image you
know and so on so they actually believed
in the true God in a God you know made
like a man
and not a woman he was a man no doubt
about that either okay he was male uh
but uh that God has been whittled down
over the years and now we have another
situation and here let me show you
what's happened okay what they did with
God they put him in the other uh uh
group okay so here you have the God and
the angel and they're moving to the
other side
okay so the so poor God you know he's uh
he used to be on one side and suddenly
he went to the other side okay and
um did it stop there no uh the
mathematicians did something different
uh well really they did the first part
the same they took the particle okay
which is their God the god they've been
praying to for the last 400 years they
took the particle and they also moved it
to the other side here let me show you
that okay so the particle was there okay
and it started moving to the other side
uh
see if I get get this guy out
give me a second here
okay the particle started moving to the
other side
and you say uh well what happened there
you know and uh yeah the these objects
these things the corpuscle they went to
the side of the concept and so God angel
Spirits all that in religion but in the
religion of mathematics right the the
real particle you know the corpuscle
with quantum mechanics it also went to
the side of the concert became a massive
concept you know now you're not talking
about a particle now you're talking
about a uh an excited field or a wave
function collapse
what is that what do you mean a wave
function collapse what has collapsed
what a physical object has collapsed a
wave function what's a function's a
mathematical concept so we have all
these numbers and they collapse and
that's the so-called particle so the
particle is no longer the particle that
we used to have okay that's changed okay
did we stop there well in the case of
mathematics okay the gods of mathematics
okay
um
you know they they not only got rid of
the particle uh meaning they moved it to
the side of the concept but they did
something else they started moving all
these other uh
Concepts they moved them to the other
side they converted them into objects
exactly the reverse and here you see how
they went to the other side okay so uh
we had all those that were objects went
to Concepts and all those that were
Concepts went through objects that's
what we have today so if you talk to
anyone today about you know God he might
talk to you about Concepts abstractions
you might say no God is love God is
intelligence
um he he's not a he we call him a he
anyways but he's not a he uh what he is
is or God is is love intelligence uh
some abstraction
um Grace you know these these words
these are the words you'll hear out
there the particle uh from mathematics
that their God also went to the Concept
side the particle became a concept so
whenever you hear the word particle
you're thinking about a little ball a
little speck of dust absolutely not the
particle of today for the last hundred
years is no longer the particle it's an
abstract concept what happened to all
the concepts of the 19th century that
they said well these are Concepts you
know mathematical Concepts they move
them into obviously they treat them as
objects so all these Gods the god of
energy the god the field God of mass you
know gravity uh Force charge plasma
vortex in the case of the electric
Universe all these are treated as
physical objects not one of these is a
physical object including the ether all
these are Concepts and yes unless you
understand the difference between an
object and a concept you're going to
have a million questions
and that's where we are today all these
people really believe that they're
moving uh objects around in their you
know juggling Concepts that's what
they're doing
okay so what can I say uh that's a
that's a situation today and I'll give
you here the conclusions okay uh here we
have it uh as long as God was a magician
we were okay and as long as he was a
bush flaming or otherwise you know just
standing still we were okay because now
we knew what God is when the magician
and the bush converted into Concepts uh
we no longer had a what
now we have a concept and a concept is
not a what and then the other side they
have all these gods they have the Higgs
they call the God particle okay and uh
that's a concept because you think of it
as a particle with a big h on its back
uh not true okay uh the Higgs is not a
particle a corpuscle a speck of dust a
grain of sand you know a seed none of
those now nothing even like that it's a
number that's what it is a bunch of
numbers in some cases but vibrating
numbers converted into one number and
that's called a Higgs a little particle
uh strings they're made out of uh
one-dimensional lines
uh if you can ever conceptualize that
and the famous One the 4D canvas of uh
general relativity unimaginable is uh Mr
um
Stephen Hawking said and what is it just
a mixture of space and time what is time
time is a concept so obviously uh we're
not talking about a physical object
despite that the mathematicians Bend
warp this abstract concept
uh good luck with that one you'll need a
lot of beers to understand that one
okay we had our science critic also okay
fellow
made a video
um and his video criticized the
scientific method can you believe
someone today in this day and age
criticizing the scientific method okay
yeah unbelievable uh anyways this is
what he had to say uh he talked about
fields in space-time and again it's got
a little bit to do with what I just
explained a little while ago okay so
let's see what this guy has to say here
he goes listen carefully
the issue that is addressed here is that
this fellow confesses that we cannot
even hope
to grasp fields and space-time
yet he claims that he understands
physical interpretations found it upon
them
so the thing is there is something there
but it's not the type of thing that our
brains can easily comprehend our brains
have evolved to deal with matter things
like fields and space-time seem
completely foreign to us but then when
you learn and study about these things
it makes it easier to understand what is
actually happening
yeah it makes it easier to understand
what what's happening when uh when you
don't know what a field is okay so we
don't know what a field is we can't
conceptualize it but once you learn
about these things oh you understand
everything yeah because uh you could
understand everything as long as you
introduce Spirits okay you say uh the
spirit did it oh okay so we're done you
what else is there to learn right and
first let me uh address the issue of
comprehension okay we do not comprehend
things
okay
here we have a rock you don't comprehend
a rock okay we don't understand
a rock okay you understand or you
comprehend When someone tells you a
story or a theory maybe he tells you uh
the movie that he watched then you say
oh I comprehend I understand what you
explained just now okay or described or
whatever but when you just point and say
rock
there's no comprehension there it's
called visualization imagining you I can
even you know once you know what a rock
is I can say mention the word rock you
don't have it in front of you I don't
point to it because we don't need to do
that anymore you just say rock and you
imagine okay I know what he's talking
about he's talking about a little thingy
there maybe your rock the one you're
imagining is a little different than the
one I'm imagining but we're both
referring to the same thing I say tree
same thing you say okay I know what a
tree is okay we we all imagine the same
thing so we do not comprehend
uh objects any more than we Define
objects we point to them and name them
so that the ET learns our language
learns the nouns you points a coconut
you're both stuck on an island say
coconut now he knows what coconut means
it's that thing there there's no real
comprehension in the sense of you know a
story uh Theory something that you know
that is lengthy a paragraph did you
understand the paragraph that's
different than when you read it right
there's a different pointing and saying
you know tree Rock chair
there is no real comprehension not in a
scientific world and maybe in the
ordinary speech world but not in the
scientific world
okay so the question is whether our
field
is a thing because he mentioned that
several times in fact he said there is
some thing met the field right there are
things there uh things like Fields seem
completely foreign to us yeah but when
you learn about these things it makes it
easier to understand what is happening
he concedes that field is not matter
okay so it's not matter
he says it's not a thing what is it what
are we talking about you know and and so
the question is uh thing that we had
which has shape we Define it very simple
very baby-like in fact that is the
scientific definition of the word thing
because every thing in the universe has
shape and that which is uh doesn't have
shape is not a thing okay that's how
simple it is an object thing entity
structure uh any of those word substance
that's all they're all the same thing
they're all the same synonyms as far as
physics is concerned okay every word in
the dictionary either has shape or
doesn't and if it doesn't it's
automatically put in the category of
Concepts okay uh shape is a static
concept you don't need to have any
Motion in in shape and a lot of people
get so confused with that they said well
everything is moving in the universe so
everything changes shape
these people I say are mentally [ __ ]
that's that's the way I treat them
because shape is a static concept and we
have to look at a cross-section of time
and people don't understand that okay so
uh but what did uh Maxwell say about
field okay the space in the neighborhood
over the of the electric and magnetic
bodies in that space there he is what
matter in motion matter in motion so uh
a field does not have shape because
field is matter in motion something is
moving inside a field and you see that
on the right lower right there you see
that a field so-called field is not a
physical object what it is it's made out
of something that is moving in that area
and for a magnet it is underwater it
pulls every iron filing one at a time
towards the magnet so a field is
something in motion matter in motion and
it pulls one iron filing at a time what
you have to identify is not the field
which is that whole region in where
something is moving in there you have to
identify the thing that is moving that's
what you have to that's the thing not
the feel field is a concept in fact it's
worse because as you can see on the
upper right the definition of field is a
quantity that has a value for each space
and time
so all we're talking about when we're
talking about a field is a bunch of
numbers what is the number well what
they do they measure the strength of the
field the strength at each place around
the magnet and they say okay the field
has a certain strength here another
strength over here and they map all
these strengths right they do that and
you can do that physically with iron
filings and they say okay we see how
strong the field is and the farther away
you get as you can see there as well
um fewer and fewer
um iron filings stick to the thing and
it gets lighter and lighter as far as
iron filings are concerned what you have
to identify what matter in motion what
matter is moving inside that field and
until you do that you won't understand
this you won't understand what a field
is okay
and so let's quickly educate this uh
poor critic okay who doesn't know what a
field is and says he understands
everything okay and here it is here we
have a running gal okay so she's running
she's moving and we always say okay
that's more or less like a field it's
got all these parts and they're all
moving okay
but what's the issue uh here let's stop
stop that's gonna we're gonna look at
the universal movie here
so on the top what you see is the gal
running but on the bottom we've
separated each one of the frames of that
film and what we're saying is that in
each frame nothing nothing at all is
moving there's not a single electron
that is moving in that uh image in other
words we're talking about a real live
image if if we talk about an actual gal
that's running out there and we take and
and God were to stop the universe okay
here we'll we'll get God to stop the
universe okay so he waves this magic
wand and now nothing moves in the
universe in fact God had better not move
either because otherwise we'd be moving
with respect to him so we we're going to
stop the universe no motion whatsoever
not a single electron moves because we
have a cross section of time we have
what we can call a frozen Universe it's
frozen until someone uh you know melts
it again okay defrosts it uh it just
stays in that in that condition okay so
there's nothing moving in a picture in a
photograph and it's so hard for all
these people to understand because they
get sidetracked they say but everything
moves in the universe we're stopping
everything we're seeing even the
electrons don't move nothing moves
and they don't understand that they
don't understand the assumption that
we're making we're saying look let's
assume we stop everything and that's
what we're seeing in one of those frames
okay what if we stop a field okay
uh this little
talked about a field
and uh we have Max always says there's
matter in motion
okay what if we had God's eyes someone
mentioned that at the beginning of today
what if you had God's eyes and you could
see
that invisible world of Mother Nature's
there what she uses to do her magic
tricks okay what is it that's moving in
a magnetic field just an example okay so
we have a magnetic field
what did Maxwell say matter in motion we
take a snapshot we have Adam Mann he can
see at his level
let's see what he what he took a
snapshot for us nothing is moving no
electron no Adam nothing in the entire
universe is moving he just took a
snapshot for us okay this is what I say
we would see okay here it is magnetic
field is comprised of countless threads
that are swinging around
here we show a single image and
obviously I didn't illustrate all the
threads okay what we're saying is if we
were to take a snapshot of a field
surrounding a magnet or two magnets like
in this case what we would see is the
pattern formed by threads that are
swinging around if you take a mere
snapshot of that well you would see just
threads just standing there Frozen in
time okay and uh so that's the matter
that was in motion that uh
Maxwell was talking about that he
couldn't figure out he he did not
understand why there was something in
Motion in there that he could not see or
touch and we're saying that you cannot
see or touch the threads that swing
around a magnet
okay so uh hopefully we answered what a
field is and yeah uh field itself is not
a what field is a bunch of numbers it's
defined as a bunch of numbers and even
from a physical point of view all
they're saying is there's matter in
Motion in that region they call field
until you understand those two concepts
you're going to be using the word field
all the time as a physical object you
say the field did this it moved the
charge or bang the charge you can't talk
like that in science you can't talk like
that in physics you can talk like that
in mathematics
okay
okay I'm gonna answer a couple questions
um comments that people made the uh
since last time and here's the first one
says if we will if we will be able to
touch and or see and or smell a concept
that would become an object yes
uh well
can we touch a concept do we understand
what we're talking about you know how
would you touch that which has no
surface that which has no shape
okay so this is what you gotta answer
and and why can't you touch a concept
because a concept is a relation
concept we Define as a word that
embodies or uh or somehow has within it
uh two objects
that's it it's a relation between two
objects so you can't touch a relation
you can touch the object but not the
relation so I guess that's the best
answer I can give them yeah you can't
touch a concept then so
just because you say you can touch it
well what did you touch did you touch
love because you put your hand down you
felt something you said oh I must have
touched love
yeah maybe
uh depends on how many beers you know
okay another fellow says candoros pass
through each other smart alec
I wouldn't think that they would be able
to because I can't draw that
poor father
he can't draw that well let me try it
for him in fact I'll do better than that
I'll draw something that goes through
something else okay here it is okay and
we have the hand going right through the
Rope so we don't even need and the hand
is made of gazillions of ropes so there
you have a rope going through a rope
more than that you have atoms going
through the Rope okay right through the
Rope you do that every day you're you're
walking through ropes constantly okay so
uh why he could draw it I don't know but
here I drew it and
um let me Point another version of this
okay here it is uh here you have let me
get rid of this one
here you have
um a hand sliding to the road because
the atoms of your hand slide through the
ropes remember the atoms you don't you
push an atom atom against Adam will push
but like if I I push the table right but
when when I approach the table I may be
going through a bunch of ropes that are
crisscrossing where I'm at and I just
slide through the atom slides through
those ropes
so you know there's there's no problem
in not touching because you're sliding
through them and as I explained earlier
with the uh formation of the atom you
know the atom can slide along a rope
okay because the atom is made out of the
same threads that make up the rope and
so it's just you know it's like uh try
to explain it the other day in a uh
interview I had you know so assume this
is the atom okay when it moves to the
next location it just goes in here in
that rope and it just keeps sliding
through it
you know this is what it's doing it's
just going through the rope and because
it's made out of the same road so in
that sense you know um
uh you're you're going through the rope
in a sense but you're not
and when you move along you know
lengthwise along the Lower Road but you
can also move across the road no problem
because you can't touch the rope uh
Mother Nature never invented touch for
her uh physical mediators and that's
what
gets everybody crazy because everybody
wants to go to the lab and prove and
there's no way you can run an experiment
to show the existence
of something that is intangible and
invisible and nevertheless that which is
exists it has nothing to do with
tangibility or visibility it has to do
with whether it's an object and whether
it has location so we don't have to have
um touching to prove the existence of
the road in fact you can't
okay and uh here's uh another photo he
says Rose Fanning out is suggesting
gravity force is reducing as the objects
get closer because the resultant force
is less so I don't know what this poor
little fellow understood but so he says
so in gatie's mind G-Force gets less and
less as two objects get closer
contradicts uh experiments uh yeah he
doesn't understand I don't even know
what he's got in his little p brain but
no it's the other way around as the
objects come closer the cube closer to
the cylinder and vice versa the ropes
fan out you have more ropes therefore
each rope is acting independently
whereas when the objects are very very
far apart there's almost a single rope
and gravity is weak meaning the force is
we but I guess uh that went over this
poor fellow's head
okay and here's a final
issue the fellow says does the Rope do
the ropes have weight
uh-huh one to five add weight to the
object falling in other words if you
have a cylinder and we have one atom
there number six and it's uh bound to uh
five atoms in the cube okay they're all
the roots are all on the same axis so we
have a single axis they're all acting as
one rope
but what happens when the cylinder moves
closer to the uh
Cube well the ropes fan out and now each
one is acting independently okay that's
why you have the uh acceleration of
gravity but he says does the Rope itself
have weight
okay and I guess he he has it in his uh
mind what people have
um
you know when when you see people who do
a tug of war real rope and real everyday
rope
um they're pulling on the rope you're
not only pulling on the other guys
you're also pulling on that rope that
rope does have weight
so that's where he's getting the idea
but the issue here is that you know the
uh first of all it's very uh hard it's
impossible to measure if that rope has
weight in that sense okay does the Rope
have weight well I can say that the
thread in the entire universe has the
entire weight of every atom in the
universe in other words the the single
thread has the weight of everything
because everything is made out of this
single thread
but what how do you weigh it uh give me
a give me a scale where I can put the
little you know the the whole thread on
top of it okay I can't do that and uh so
can you say that the thread has weight
well the only way you can have weight is
with respect to something else and
that's what weight is in in the case of
these two objects there but what's the
issue the the Rope you know when when
you're pulling tugging you're in a tug
of war one group against another you
really feel the weight of the other
people that's the one because it's it's
lengthwise along the Rope so in that
sense if you're just looking at the
direction okay that rope essentially has
no weight it's not like uh when you're
pulling something from Against Gravity
right then uh not only are you pulling
on the box but you're also pulling on a
rope that you're using to pull the box
but when you're pulling on someone else
it's like you know you're you're pulling
along the Rope you're really pulling
along them you're not really pulling
Against Gravity or you are in a way you
know because the Rope does have weight
but here you don't have weight of the
Rope because for the Rope to have weight
it would have to be with respect to the
Center of the Earth each rope
individually but the Rope is not tied to
the Earth each one of those ropes the
Rope is tied to the atom in another uh
object that rope that specific rope so
that rope does not have weight because
in order for it to have weight it would
have to be somehow bound to every atom
on Earth and that rope is not bound to
every atom on Earth so it's putting a
long lengthwise from one atom to the
other it's like the Rope weren't wasn't
there because as far as resistance or
anything like that the resistance
carried out by the other object the
other thing is the tension on the Rope
which is what it is there's no Pull the
Rope does not pull what you have is
tension between two atoms and that
tension is always maintained by the
velocity the constant C of the velocity
of light it'll see 300 000 kilometers
per second that is a measure of the uh
of the tension on the Rope uh you know
it's just one rope tied to another atom
you're not pulling on the earth or
anything like that it's not tied to
every atom on Earth so it doesn't have
weight in that sense okay anyways here I
try to summarize some things for them is
that the ropes are parallel with weight
that's one issue okay the object is
perpendicular to weight and what do we
mean by that well it's tied to every
atom on Earth so you're pulling on the
whole earth in a sense when you're
pulling on the box okay the ropes are
taught tension versus Force again you're
talking about it be intense not pulling
okay and that's people have a lot of
trouble with that as well when tug of
war teens pull they feel the weight of
the Rope that's an ordinary uh days why
because every atom that forms the Rope
is bound to every atom on Earth but
that's not the case with the
electromagnetic rope which is a single
rope connecting one atom to the atom
that you're pulling on you know like in
the case you're pulling on a box you
know uh if if you were to pull just one
rope one electromagnetic rope right tied
to one atom uh the Rope not no part of
that rope is tied to uh because not has
doesn't have Parts it's tied to every
atom on Earth so it doesn't have weight
okay and atom does not pull on another
and there is tension along a rope
between
uh any two atoms
with that I'll see you on Sunday and uh
hopefully I get to invite my son he was
not able to come today but hopefully
he'll be here next week